well the black lives matter protests in
the US have resonated around the world
including here in Germany which is now
reexamining its own attitudes towards
race today the federal
anti-discrimination agency has presented
its annual report its findings shows
that the country has an ongoing racism
problem that's having serious
consequences
Germany is slowly waking up to the issue
of discrimination but the number of
cases is on the rise there were three
thousands 580 reported cases of
discrimination in 2019 stuff year of the
DA what kind of food safety e there
shouldn't be any gaps in protection in
the long term and this is an important
in his right moon that Selena is the
first state to have pastors and
anti-discrimination law shortly the
country's latest report looks at
discrimination based on gender
disability age religion sexual identity
and worldview but the largest issue
remains racial discrimination most of
the cases in 2019 33 percent were
classified as racist discrimination a
thousand and 176 reported cases last
year more than double compared to four
years ago in the report some
participants cited their experiences two
colleagues from another department
approached me laughing and asked me if I
worked at the company to make coffee hi
I'm a civil engineer from Syria a cadet
school insulted my brother because he's
got dark skin then he hit him the
teacher saw everything but did nothing
the report comes at a time when a new
awareness towards everyday
discrimination is raised following
protests denouncing police violence to
its people of color all over the world
let's get some perspective on this with
Peggy pichia she's a cultural and
literary scholar a policy advisor on
diversity and D coloniality at the
federal agency for civic education Peggy
thank you for joining us I want to ask
you about what we just heard in our
report there are examples of someone
being demeaned in the workplace physical
and verbal abuse over the color of
someone's skin is that representative of
the type of discrimination and racism
faced here in Germany thank you for
having me yes unfortunately I have to
say that is very representative and we
have these cases over and over again and
in your video you already showed that in
Berlin just declared and and came out
with an anti-discrimination law and it
is all also means that in Berlin there
was a consultation process process with
the black community on their experiences
on discrimination over the last two
years and this is also where a lot of
this information came out we actually we
know about that we know about police
brutality we have these cases open as
well so we could look at it more
directly here in Germany Peggy I want to
ask you about a discussion that's being
had right now in Germany about whether
racism here is systemic and structural
do you think it is yes it is structural
and I think we really need to look at it
and look at the history of the German
mentality how we actually developed this
idea of German s which is very much tied
to the idea of whiteness so German
national identity still equals whiteness
in many hats and regardless of
development of our laws and integration
laws but it is really going back to the
Enlightenment period where the idea of
German is was developed and which
directly led also in
to colonialism we never really tackled
this face it's not a face actually this
very influential a period of German
history and and that's very much led to
an involvement in everydays racism in a
structural way we can see that for
example that was in the German discourse
we don't have enough language to talk
about racism to talk about the
experience of black people we always
look rather to the United States well
now there are efforts Peggy to tackle
this a census initiative to collect
information on the black community here
in Germany there's more discussion about
discrimination as you said do you see
this as a turning point and how we talk
about race and racism here in Germany I
don't know if it is a turning point it
is very important that it's necessary
that we get also more statistics more
numbers but it is also important that we
as a society look to this problem every
day and see where we can where we can
change the way we look at the German
society we look at the idea of who is
included and who can't possibly be a
member of the Society so by including
and collecting more data on black people
and their experience in in Germany we
hope to contribute to this discussion to
this to this discourse but there has to
be more than Peggy pichia cultural
cultural and literary scholar policy
advisor thank you very much for joining
us thank you for having me well the
black lives matter protest in the US
have resonated around the world
including here in Germany which is now
we examining its own attitudes towards
racism later this month for the first
time a nationwide survey will ask black
people about the discrimination they
face in their everyday lives
as what I would Beckstrom is one of
about a million black people in Germany
but nobody knows that for sure as there
are no official figures she grew up in
Leipzig as the daughter of Sudanese
exchange students after the fall of the
Berlin Wall
life in East Germany in the 90s was
difficult for black people many of them
felt left alone lift em up early on when
a right-wing mob circles around you at a
fair and there's a policeman standing
around who just lets it happen as 15
people shout the n-word at you memories
like this often make you doubt whether
you're really welcome in this country
and that's why the organization's each
one teach one
and citizens of Europe are conducting a
survey the afro census the first one on
black people's lives in Germany Daniel
jammer hopes it will fill the gaps
fortunately there has been far too
little research in recent decades on the
situation of black people and on anti
black racism in Germany that explains
why politicians keep asking us well
what's the problem there blacks here at
all
they find it difficult to talk about
black people that's why we've decided to
take matters into our own hands
maracanã Zender is hopeful she's from
France and works as a teacher in Berlin
she's upset at the lack of sensitivity
even among some well-meaning white
people my class and I prepared a song
the kids were super super motivated they
were doing well and then they got stage
fright the principal of the school turn
around to the whole assembly and stated
I just love like use it don't you and
you're like interesting but the real
problem and the real question is like
how kids they know if there are no
numbers
there are no recording and no one
talking about it the average census
wants to facilitate precisely this
discussion and to better capture
everyday racism in German society but it
also has another effect in poem
ultimately it's also very empowering for
those who are black and I think that's
great
there's never been a survey like the
off-road census before Germany is
reluctant to collect statistics on
citizens according to ethnic criteria
there's always a reluctance to ask
communities about their situation about
whether they are discriminated against
people are afraid that this kind of
research will create these communities
but we are here we are part of this
society we won't be denied the right to
exist and we can all speak about black
people asking people calmly without
being afraid of it it's hoped it could
be a step towards change